vous avez vu j'ai fait du porte à porte
de quoi les gens vous ont parlé ça peut
aller de nos préoccupations comme la
réfection des rues et l'âge et les
rencontres avec monsieur jean françois
parenteau le maire on va discuter de ces
dossiers là jusqu'à la ruelle verte
l'économie l'emploi la rue wellington la
promenade rolling stone est un projet
fabuleux parce que verdon est une ville
en pleine transformation et les
commerçants s'unissent pour que la rue
wellington représente une force
économique que des gens de l'île des
soeurs ils viennent de manière le retour
d'une grande rue marchand oui un voisin
oui et on parle de l'hôpital l'hôpital
est crucial c'est il va falloir qu'il y
ait une expansion une modernisation de
l'hôpital et seul le parti québécois a
donné son appui
ça fait des années que sous le parti
libéral ce projet là est en dormance et
les logements sociaux
ici il ya des genres et beaucoup de
jeunes familles qui ont déménagé à qui
il ya pouvoir d'attraction dans verdun
en ce moment il ya beaucoup de jeunes
familles qui viennent me voir mais il ya
un niveau aussi de pauvreté et pour
madame marois elle annoncé 7500 nouveaux
logements sociaux sur l'île de montréal
avait aussi une priorité accordée au sud
ouest vous avez commencé à parler aux
citoyens peu de quoi vous parlez gens
des c'est amusant parce que une des
grandes préoccupations ici c'est
l'hôpital vous en avez entendu parler et
alain verdin qui croule vieux mais la
chose qui est fascinant sur ça c'est que
j'y suis né voyez-vous et à cet hôpital
à l'époque mes parents tenaient ce que
ce que je viens au monde dans un hôpital
lot parce que on avait personnel dédié
pire et moderne
on accorde le personnel dédié il faudra
s'en occuper il ya des chants bouillot
carte passionne dans laquelle n'y a pas
de salle de bain
vraiment mesquin engagements précis
n'encense pas écouté il y aura des
engagements publics sont peu au moment
où on parle royaume de santé vis éric
parsy on est très systémique dans notre
approche bien clair qu'on peut pas avoir
un hôpital comme celui là qu'une
vocation important et ne pas se
préoccuper de pinard le logement on est
en train de changer et il y aura 125 140
le 4e ville a été fait bien sûr on est
en banlieue de morlaix et maintenant
venant du centre-ville de montréal roch
entre les maisons qui sont à la fin de
leur vie utile sont reconstruites
bayonne tentation de reconstruire des
chaussures d'eau coûte cher ça pourrait
changer le tissu social il faut boisseau
verdun c'est verdun avec ses
spécificités et pour moi sur cette
préoccupation